this is a little unusual but I brought a
friend of mine in who I've worked with
for many years His Brilliant writer on
the show and he's helped us out uh Matt
right over there hi and I'm not usually
here no no no and I we don't Matt and I
don't get along but I invited him
not that I would know yeah but um it'll
come out don't worry but uh Matt
um all we've known each other since for
how long since
2007.07.7 okay it feels like 09 but
anyway
um we've known each other since 2007
every day he comes in he wants to talk
to me about Metallica
every single day and he plays me what he
tells me what you're up to and I
appreciate it because I'm a fan as well
but I thought I feel like I should
apologize
it's been great it's been great to not
break common ground for for almost 20
years it's been but uh but man you uh
you were on in New York and you found
out that Lars was going to be here today
yeah
how many shows have you been to uh 62
yeah oh wow what was your first one
Atlanta 93. okay so that'd be I think it
was the live do you remember him
yeah yeah yeah wait a minute wait a
minute wow wait a minute how did you
know that Lakewood amphitheater yeah I
um if if if we go around a room and you
say Atlanta you say uh Louisville and
you say uh whatever Dallas Houston I can
pretty quickly identify the venue
remember the shows and uh that's crazy
and remember the tours and stuff yeah I
don't know my children's name okay let's
try one on here
Antarctica yeah
Antarctica was uh December 13th wow yeah
it's uh
this weird
uh people are very generous they call it
encyclopedia like I it it and I often
Play Along on that uh tangent uh I I do
feel increasingly that you know if you
put me James and Kurt together in the
same room we can pretty much as three of
us make a hole and we can remember all
of it 100 but I remember all the dates
so if you say
excuse me if you say uh blah blah blah
uh where were you uh you know February
08 I can go we were right there we
played there we played this venue and
uh but Atlanta I mean has always been
great in Lakewood and the Omni yeah the
Omni with the Army there anymore right
but but what's amazing about the fact
that you remember it's every city had an
Amphitheater that looked kind of the
same which was just that rake with a
lawn in the back so the fact that you
remember specifically that it was called
like because that must they must all
look the same yeah from the stage it was
a lot easier back in the day because
uh you know 20 30 years ago when we came
up sort of the 80s and 90s
all the venues whether they were you
know coliseum's auditoriums or Arenas uh
or the amphitheaters they all had
geographical primarily geographical
names so if you were in you know Phoenix
it was the Phoenix Municipal Auditorium
right and if you were in Atlanta it was
Lake or it was the Omni or was attached
to the CNN Center or whatever now when
you go to all these places every one of
them is called the FedEx building yes
or the State Farm Insurance and so you
can't kind of keep track because the
naming rights of those change every
couple three five years so you're
sitting there going did I play this
before yeah you know and and what the
bank bought them yeah yeah and so but
I'll tell you at the depend Center you
know in Orlando and you're just
damn it why did they buy it Astro Glide
Arena
God knows we've played all of them
actually we played uh to the the
continents thing um one year on the
Justice tour in 88-89 we were 46 or 47
States into it and would realize
you know should we go for 50.
so uh there was depends on what the
other ones are yeah
there was no there's no Arena or at
least at that time there was no arena in
Delaware and there was no arena in
Vermont so in Vermont we played a high
school gymnasium and
um and in I love that and Delaware we
played a club maybe a Stone Balloon or
something I think it was called and uh
and so we ended up playing all all 50 of
of the state because at that time you
know hitting Honolulu and hitting anchor
which was a fairly regular stop Sullivan
Arena up in Anchorage and the NBC Arena
uh in uh in Honolulu or regular Parts
this reminds me of I was that um Bill
Lyman was the
um famously the bass player for the
Rolling Stones for you know a good good
chunk of their run and he had he had he
was the encyclopedia
but of a specific thing you know
everyone would think like oh my God you
were there you were there for all these
seminal moments and you were in uh this
amazing rock band and you went through
this incredible time and apparently when
you read through his Diaries it's all we
played this venue here's how much we got
paid uh here's how much I put in this I
put in this much for the cab I took home
and then I charged this much for the dry
cleaning then we paid
yeah no I've heard that story yeah yeah
and it's over and like hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of pages and you
think how about was there a moment where
Jagger irritated you or should you not
have been an accountant yeah or even
better was there a moment where you guys
really connected as a rock and roll band
to an audience what does that have to do
with how much money I got paid and how
much money the cab cost
um no but his yeah his his accountant
was thrilled with him